tonight on the new reality back to
school I think moving forward learning
might never be the same I think it'll be
better the future of meat processing
what the plants look like precoded are
not what they look like currently and I
don't think that's what the plants will
look like post Kovac virus mysteries we
know that there are people that don't
have any symptoms related to kovat 19
the many questions that remain how many
people have actually been affected we
don't know that at all
Colvin and climate change the twin
crises if we need this kind of reduction
every year we don't want to have a
pandemic to do that and the new reality
of concerts right now this is the best
that we can do to bring people together
and bring live music back
[Music]
hello I'm Donna Friesen here we are in
the middle of June and nothing is as it
should be students who are graduating or
quietly moving on the traditional
celebrations a thing of the past and the
last few months of education have been
less than ideal since the beginning of
the pandemic the United Nations has
monitored school closures around the
world at the peak more than 91 percent
of the world's students were out of
class that's close to 1.6 billion
children some places have begun
reopening schools just over 20 European
countries for example have allowed kids
back in class but with restrictions and
there have been setbacks in France
within days of reopening there were
outbreaks and several schools had to
close again after 70 students and staff
tested positive for koban 19 for those
still open it hasn't been business as
usual by any means there are smaller
classes cafeterias are closed lockers
are out of use libraries off-limits here
in North America most states and
provinces have been cautious there have
been limited reopening in a handful of
American States and in Canada several
provinces of welcomed students and
teachers back but it's not business as
usual in Quebec
one of the first jurisdictions on the
continent to reopen classes
it wasn't province-wide in the Montreal
metropolitan area the region hit hardest
by kovin 19 schools are still closed
where they are open we wanted to see how
things have gone our Mike Armstrong went
to Howick Elementary just an hour
outside Montreal getting back into class
has been a learning experience for
everyone and some of the lessons could
be applied across Canada when the
parents pull up and drop their kids off
things at Howick elementary school look
normal you notice what's not normal when
the buses pull up basically the numbers
instead of 30 or 40 kids this bus drops
off four classes are optional and a lot
of parents have decided to keep their
kids home for those who did come back
this last part of the year is sort of a
dry run for the Fall
kids that are here now are gonna be
better off in September than the ones
that are just coming straight back
that's what I think that's kind of what
we thought about it how akela mentoree
would normally have 170 students
kindergarten to grade six right now it
has just 40 students so it is a
challenge
Bob butters heads the new frontiers
School Board loses attendance board wide
is running at about 29% there's been
various reason why parents have chosen
to keep the children home the first one
is absolutely there's still the fear of
catching the virus no question about it
now when the school reopened there were
a ton of changes one of them limiting
access while students are in class
journalists aren't allowed in the
building they did let us in after school
so it's a little strange but principal
Melanie primo agreed to take one of our
small cameras inside to show us how
things are going
although I'll even get the door for you
no thank you
the first thing you notice is the
physical distancing the desks are far
apart and that's where kids spend most
of their time in fact to cut down on
possible transmission of kovat 19 a lot
of the school is closed the lunch rooms
not being used the library is not being
used our gymnasium is not really used as
a gymnasium our outside play structures
can't be used there are new markings on
the floors of the hallways everyone's
supposed to stay to the right and to
keep two meters from the people in front
of them which leads to the question can
you even get kids to physically distance
I'd say 95% of the time yes but we're
human and sometimes we cross paths and
we back up I'd say the biggest challenge
is outside when they're playing one of
my phys ed teachers actually organizes
games for them outside to sort of teach
them how to play social distance style
no it's your recess the staff is
adapting and some of it's a little
strange the soccer balls that usually
get cleaned once a year are now
sanitized several times a day
and there's also a new activity students
are bringing their personal bikes to
school for gym class
the bikes it's just to have another
activity to have them able to use some
equipment because it's hard to land out
equipment unless we're washing it every
single time
some Quebec schools that reopened have
had setbacks in the first three weeks
close to 50 students tested positive and
more than 30 staff that despite all the
preventive measures the new frontiers
board hasn't had a student test positive
they've been a little less lucky on the
staff side I believe we've had four
staff members who have been tested since
we came back in May 11th and I believe
only one of them was positive and that
person is fine now we bit we've been
fortunate as a school board to have not
had a high number of cases that we've
had to involve testing but you watch for
that I would imagine
we certainly daily I mean that's one of
the roles big roles of the principal and
the staff here at the school and we urge
parents and children to not come to
school if you're not feeling well when
the province made the move to reopen
schools the argument was that while
there was a danger it was outweighed by
the potential damage kids with learning
difficulties need to be monitored and
for others sitting at home for months
mental health can be an issue but the
partial return with smaller classes has
led schools find what works and what
doesn't the maximum number of students
in a class was supposed to be 15 they
found 11 is pretty much the maximum if
you want to let kids stand up the school
also now has an indoor and an outdoor to
help with social distancing and they're
working on new ways to send homework and
notes home with students we don't even
know if the kids are going to be able to
bring things things home so we've
decided as a staff to not buy agendas
the big issue right now is communication
inside the school across the school
board and across the country
go back is being watched and sharing its
experiences some experts predict this
pandemic will lead to major changes in
education everything from the rethinking
of the school calendar to new ways of
teaching the new frontiers board barely
did any online instruction before this
now it's something new it brings to the
table going forward
it's sticking around I think will be a
better system with the ability to have
blended learning time will tell I think
moving forward
learning might never be the same I think
it'll be better
[Music]
no matter what industry you work in
whether you've lost your job are working
from home or have the kind of job where
you can't stay home every Canadian
workplace has felt the effects of koban
19 among the hardest hit are meat
processing plants where outbreaks have
infected hundreds of workers
it was so bad at some of the plants they
had to close meat processing is big
business about 65,000 people work in the
industry in Canada all the facilities
now are back in operation with new
safety measures in place but the virus
has sent a shudder through the industry
it is vulnerable and so is our food
supply
is it time for a fundamental rethink of
how its structured heather Eurex West is
looking into that me and my siblings
keep saying that he was the best I mean
little because he truly was 51 year old
Benito Quesada died from kovin 19 in
hospital on May 7th
leaving behind a wife four children and
an empty space that will never be filled
we haven't touched anything of his his
boots are still there in the entryway
toothbrush his cologne everything still
there Quezada worked at the Cargill
meatpacking plant in High River Alberta
he took a $500 bonus to keep working
after employees started to get sick soon
he was infected too and for weeks he lay
in a hospital ICU fighting for his life
he's always drawing he's on that
protects us and in seeing him there
super vulnerable I had never seen him
like that
Quesada was the second worker at the
Cargill plant to die of kovat nineteen
sixty seven-year-old hip Bowie passed
away in April the plant closed on April
20th after bouys death in all at least
943 Cargill employees tested positive
and more than 1500 cases were linked to
the plant it was the largest outbreak
from a single site in Canada meanwhile
there were 661 workers infected at the
jbs beef plant in Brooke
Alberta and one of those workers died
these plants are a perfect place for a
virus to spread they are cold and most
of them are laid out like this jbs plant
in the United States workers standing
elbow to elbow on the cutting line
unlike Cargill the jbs plant in Alberta
was never shut down because of the
outbreak but it did scale down
operations cutting production to just
one shift a day it's now back to running
two shifts of workers but inside it is
far from business as usual
that's because until there's a vaccine
both the company and its workers are
very aware that another outbreak could
happen at any time
so they've introduced PPE so that people
are wearing masks and advisors they've
put plastic barriers between individual
people working in the plant in order to
reduce the flow of air between between
individuals
they've staggered people start and
finish times they've staggered breaks to
reduce the density they've put dividers
in buses and increased the number of
buses so far those measures seem to be
working as of this week there were only
two active cases among workers at
Cargill and jbs and no new outbreaks
have been reported but some workers
still don't feel safe actually I have
friend they still stay in the house now
they said that no I don't want to go
back because we're scared
Remiel NBI tested positive for Kovan 19
in late April even though she had no
symptoms
the single mom returned back to work at
jbs last week she says she feels safe
but she knows many of her co-workers
have been reluctant to return for an
industry that was facing a labor
shortage before this pandemic that's a
big problem it's one of the reasons we
have often new immigrants working in
these plants because they're not jobs
that that everybody wants so even before
the risk of infection through kovat
which we've now reduced that these
plants often had trouble filling jobs as
meat processors inch back towards full
production balancing worker safety and
profitability will become
difficult but it also may not be
possible to keep workers physically
distant in existing factories that could
mean higher meat prices for Canadians in
the short term but in the long term the
Canadian meat council says there may be
bigger changes coming when I said to a
few few people in government is what the
plants look like freek ovid are not what
they look like currently and I don't
think that's what the plants will look
like post Kovac
what I do think it has done is advance
the discussion of whether or not you
would want to look at having more
automation in your plants and I think on
balance most of the plants are looking
at that at some level this might be a
sneak peek at the future at this pork
plant in Denmark machines do much of the
cutting that humans do in North America
Tyson's always been a company that's
been out on the forefront of innovation
just last year u.s. meat processing
giant Tyson Foods opened this sparkling
new facility in Arkansas to develop new
technology automating many of its
production processes and in 2015 jbs
bought Scott technologies a New Zealand
company that specializes in robot
butchers we developed the world's first
lamb x-ray primal this promotional video
from here at the jbs lamb processing
plant in Australia shows how the company
uses sophisticated technology like
artificial intelligence to automate some
meat cutting jobs that humans used to do
does that by x-raying every animal as an
individual animal and identifying where
the fourth and fifth rib are and where
that hindquarter cut is and that's the
whole purpose of that x-ray primal
machine x-rays and CT scanners are used
to create a 3d model of the shape and
size of the carcass before the cutting
starts Scott technologies claims this
results in 90% accuracy the machines are
also faster and over time these robot
butchers keep getting better at their
job and unlike humans they don't get
sick or injured and they don't need
breaks or benefits the technology has
already significantly reduced the number
of workers on the cutting lines
Automation could make meat plants much
safer when the next virus hits it could
also mean fewer jobs
but as the Quezada family tries to find
small moments of joy without their
husband and father they're not thinking
about that now my family is devastated
and this time is very hard every day
every day it's very tough they're just
trying to come to terms with the loss
with me from Fort Collins Colorado is
Temple Grandin she's a professor of
animal science at Colorado State
University she's an author inventor
lecture and designer of livestock
handling facilities all over North
America her thinking process is based
more on visual images than words and her
autism gives her a unique ability to
understand how animals see the world and
her skills have helped meat processors
and slaughterhouses handle animals in a
more humane way and she's a female
trailblazer in a mostly male industry
Temple Grandin thanks for joining us
given what you know about meat
processing plants how many people work
there how closely they work hundreds of
workers who have become sick with koban
19 what grade do you give the industry
for how its responded to the pandemic
well I've actually worked hard to
respond to it Kovach attacks where
people are crammed together whether it's
cruise ships prisons aircraft carriers
any place where they're together and
actually the the plants seem to be
recovering now I just talked to two port
plants two days ago and they tested
everybody in the plant and there were
many positives but the interesting thing
is is that half of those positives had
no symptoms so something's going on here
with the virus but the virus attacks
people that are indoors close together
no matter where it is yeah there's so
many unanswered questions still about
how this virus spreads and how its
transmitted meat-processing I know you
know has changed so much in the last few
decades you've been a part of that it's
also become so centralized in these big
factories that process I think two to
six thousand cattle a day in some cases
as many as twenty thousand pigs a day
happy
I'm too big to be resilient that's a
problem but the problem of big is
fragile is not just meat it's also the
semiconductor industry it's also the
pharmaceutical industry and
semiconductors we rely on three
factories in the world for the heart of
your computer the heart of your phone
pharmaceuticals raw materials coming
from China and India common generic
drugs container ships are now infected
that's like 80% of all our trade big is
fragile now the thing about big is it's
very efficient large meatpacking plant
can do a really good animal welfare they
can do really good food safety but when
it breaks you've got real big problems
in the supply chain biggest fragile it's
very cost effective very economical a
more distributed supply chain will not
get disrupted but it's going to cost
more I don't care if it's meat or
whether it's semiconductors or whether
it's pharmaceuticals just looking
specifically at the meat industry for a
moment though what role do you think
automation should or could play in the
future - I guess eliminate some of the
fragility at least from a human
perspective well some of the jobs are
difficult to automate automation is easy
when you have like a part that you're
making that every one of them is exactly
the same animals have got biological of
variability now biggest fragile for
other reasons - storms natural disasters
war possibly is another thing that makes
biggest fragile so what do you think
you're so good at analyzing systems what
do you think a possible solution is now
is it sort of breaking down these huge
let's look at meat processing
specifically breaking down these huge
processors into smaller players across
the country the way it used to be well I
think what's happening is what's good is
similar to the beer market you know
right here in Fort Collins where I live
we've got the great big Coors plant but
then you have all these little tiny
craft breweries and I think it's gonna
be more local things like this you will
when I first went in the industry in
Arizona we had our two big ones that
would cut
Swift's and then we had a bunch of what
I call medium-sized plants so we had
Arizona beef we had her says Arizona
beef might do 400 Katla day it was not a
locker plant but the to all the other
smaller plants are maybe one third of
the beef supply now those little plants
the smaller plants have have they
couldn't compete with the big guys
so what's it happened in other
industries like beer for example is you
don't try to compete with the big guys
you do something that's special so if
there are there are micro breweries now
that are doing very well you're
suggesting micro meat processing well
that's actually some of this is starting
to happen in fact I went to New Zealand
two years ago and they have rather small
plants to call boutique plants and
they'll put out very specific orders a
hundred boxes of some special cut to
send to Japan for example so if we want
meat processing that is both humane as
possible for the animals and safe as
possible for the human workers do you
think we're going to have to prepare to
pay more for meat big concentrated
supply chains are fragile the paradox is
big is very efficient big can do a
really good job food safety animal
welfare at whatever but it's fragile and
if you go to a more distributed supply
chain it's going to be less prone to
disruption I don't care what product it
is but it's gonna cost more that's the
paradox I don't care what product it is
meat semiconductors pharmaceuticals
pharmaceutical supply chain the big
really big example of big is fragile
just one more question about the
industry I know you're closely connected
to the the meat industry do you think
they have a handle now on the spread of
kovat 19 and or do you think we might
continue to see outbreaks in these
processing plants I think the plants
have got a handle on that now we're
going to get outbreaks son what's gonna
happen in the restaurants who knows
that's a bigger worry right now then the
plants I think that's gotten under
control there the weekly slaughter rates
are going back up that's a very good
sign that they have a handle on it I'm
looking at my cattle buyers
and they said that the capacity of the
plant sir they're ramping it up that
means they're getting it under control
they would some of these plants got down
to half capacity you know now the
industry is running about 8090 percent
now that's actually good still ahead we
will make an incredible summer memory
together drive-in concerts the new
reality with country music star Brett
Kissel plus you all get up every morning
to get into our cars you drive kovat and
climate change not only learn I think we
can do this things that look better the
negative and positive impacts of the
pandemic on the environment and learning
lessons is not just a respiratory
illness and burning questions why have
some populations been resistant and
others have been explosive breaking down
the Kovach mysteries that remain
[Music]
it feels like the whole world is in a
war against an unconventional enemy the
novel coronavirus has disrupted modern
society on a scale most people alive
today have never witnessed it's been
about four and a half months since the
first case was confirmed in Canada and
we began to realize the insidious spread
there are now more than seven-and-a-half
million cases around the world and it's
known to have killed more than four
hundred and twenty thousand people the
majority of those who get it survive and
do recover that is the good news so is
the fact the daily number of new cases
in Canada almost everywhere is in
decline but as we begin to reopen the
economy the risk remains there are still
so many unknowns about how this virus is
transmitted how it attacks the body and
why some people die and others show no
symptoms we all want answers but what
we've got right now are lots of
questions tonight we explore some of the
big ones
we'll keep living in this new reality
with the threat of the virus lurking as
long as it keeps outsmarting us it's
still moving faster than our best
scientists leaving us chasing many
unknowns even one of America's most
experienced infectious disease experts
dr. Anthony Fauci who has studied HIV
and Ebola says the novel coronavirus is
his worst nightmare like oh my goodness
when is it gonna end it really is very
complicated so we're just at almost the
beginning
among the biggest questions is who who
has it how many people have actually
been infected we don't know that at all
the mystery of the asymptomatic the
so-called silent spreaders is
confounding people infected with a virus
who never show any symptoms and could be
fueling the pandemic without knowing it
one of the reasons why kovat has been
such a successful virus it's able to
fill people's lungs and have them expel
that and spread it without feeling safe
in that sense it's it's one of the most
frightening viruses that I could think
of frightening and the subject of
intense debate on Monday a top doctor at
the World Health Organisation's seemed
to dismiss a symptomatic spread it still
appears to be rare that an asymptomatic
individual actually transmits onward by
Tuesday after pushback from many
epidemiologists she clarified what she
meant what we need to better understand
is how many of the people in the
population don't have symptoms and
separately how many of those individuals
go on to transmit to others it's
perplexing and needs much more research
but some initial studies show between 25
to 45 percent of infected people have no
symptoms doctors in Canada are noticing
it taz Lehman mg is an emergency room
physician at Humber River Hospital in
Toronto so first of all have you had any
fevers no no fever chills every patient
who arrives here is screened for Kovan
19 symptoms so whenever we see a patient
we're thinking about the different
potential diagnoses now kovat 19 is a
part of almost every one of those lists
of possibilities that you're thinking
about in your head when you're trying to
help a patient because it presents it
presents in different ways and because
we know that there are people that don't
have any symptoms related to kovat 19 at
least not on our typical list of
symptoms that we'll still test positive
patients who come in for other reasons
with no apparent coded symptoms are
testing positive it's a virus that's
unpredictable some patients have no
symptoms and we've seen that like we've
been surprised with some patients
came in with a hip fracture and have no
symptoms of kovat at all but are
positive it's still believed people who
were most infectious are those with
serious respiratory symptoms but the
possibility of silent invisible spread
persists and will only be revealed
through widespread repeated testing if
you just rely on testing people who come
forward the symptoms you're going to
miss a very large number of people with
the disease and they're the ones driving
community spread a huge chunk of this is
getting ahold of people who are
transmitting before they know they're
transmitting what in what ways is Kovac
19 attacking the body and confounding
doctors in the ICU dr. Jamie Spiegelman
has seen firsthand the myriad of ways
kovat 19 can bombard the human body this
is not just a respiratory illness it
starts as a respiratory illness yeah
we've seen heart failure from it we've
seen kidney failure from it it affects
every organ so it's clearly a systemic
disease studies in the US and the UK
suggests more than a third of kovat 19
patients who end up in ICU experienced
kidney failure well we've noticed in our
ICU as patients that go on dialysis who
get renal failure from this however way
worse outcomes most of those patients
from our experience die it's as dramatic
a range is that some get only mildly ill
others die it's a mystery why in some
people the virus drives the immune
system into overdrive the body starts to
attack its own cells so we know that
most of the sickness are the things that
kill you or make you very very sick is
actually your body responding so your
immune response to this assault on your
system is the thing that makes you go to
the hospital the cytokine storm we call
it and for those who make it through
there could be lasting harm what we have
been discovering that when kovat is able
to really get into you systemically it
causes damage in the heart it causes
damage in the liver it causes damage to
the kidneys it's why testing people
already dealing with other diseases is
vitally important
and this is also why you're seeing now
more rigorous testing in populations
certainly in the populations of people
that have kidney disease that are
dialysis patients where where is the
virus headed how is it mutating we don't
know it's mutation rate really and in
fact if it's mutating in one direction
or another all viruses mutate the
mystery is what's the novel coronavirus
doing how fast is it changing and could
it become more dangerous or less it
mutates less frequently than the
influenza virus on average I've seen
estimates of one to two mutations per
month and these mutations are important
to track early signs are tending to the
positive in this respect the forces of
evolution might lean in our favor the
nature of mutation is that selective
pressure is put upon it by the
environment determine which mutations
thrive so there is a theory these
pathogens mutate towards lesser
lethality when when can we assume we are
immune to it or can we in the absence of
a vaccine immunity is emerging as a
potential key to resuming normal life
it's hoped those who have had kovat 19
are now immune to it but that's all it
is hope there is no evidence why why are
some people hit hard by it and others
barely get sick
some people do well and and recover and
not get that sick whereas other people
might get very very sick with this
infection who otherwise are of the same
age
men seem more vulnerable children seem
less so though some are developing a
mysterious multi-system inflammatory
syndrome we've seen centenarians survive
and healthy young adults succumb why are
these people not symptomatic and why
other people are so symptomatic that
they end up on life support machines and
ICU so we don't completely understand
that as well
it's not like the virus is any different
so there must be some genetic
predisposition scientists are searching
for genetic signs that might help
explain the extreme variations in
vulnerability
one study zeroed in on regions of the
human genome that could be associated
with a higher risk of respiratory
failure the same study found a 50%
increase in patients with type A blood
were in need of oxygen or a ventilator
I've heard one person call this the dark
matter of immunity why have some
populations been resistant and others
have been explosive it's not just about
the age demographic and this might be a
good thing it might mean that we reach
herd immunity sooner it might mean that
the ceiling for explosiveness of this
disease is lower than we thought but
again it's a mystery how how will this
end or are we going to be living with
the novel coronavirus
for a long time no one alive today has
lived through a pandemic like this we're
not used to such uncertainty unable to
plan for the next month the next year we
will adapt and we will keep learning I
don't expect to be afraid of this
disease by this time next year that
won't be because of a vaccine just be
because we will know better how to treat
it and people need not die of it at the
same rate that they're dying now maybe
it will turn out better than we feared
but we need to confront the possibility
some things may turn out worse than we
hoped
the Chicago woman in her 20s recovered
from kovin 19 but it devastated her
lungs and she underwent a double lung
transplant which raises another
lingering question is what happens when
you're infected and you get serious
disease and you recover what are the
long-term durable negative effects of
that infection we don't have enough
experience because we've only been
involved
months coming up we need this kind of
reduction every year between crises you
could probably see a 4050 percent
reduction in the number of smoggy days
how much the Koba 19 pandemic is really
moving the needle on climate change
[Music]
the upside to the pandemic is in the air
it's cleaner there's less pollution
because we're flying lasst driving less
an industry has slowed to almost a halt
greenhouse gas emissions plunged in
april by about 17 percent overall in
some countries the drop was more like 40
percent that is great news and it feels
like nature is rebalancing a bit that
was Jeff's simple explains it's just a
blip in the big picture of climate
change Paul Koch woke up one morning
last month
to find a trespasser taking a dip so I
called my wife and said there's a moose
in the pool the 800-pounder made quite a
splash for several hours before making
her own way out of the backyard Koch and
his wife have lived in this suburban
Ottawa neighborhood for 40 years but
this was a first we've had lots of pool
parties over the years but not one with
a moose or any animal with humans living
in lockdown the animal kingdom is
reclaiming some territory in Thailand
these monkeys are going ape embroiled in
a street fight over food in the center
of town wild turkeys are strolling the
suburbs of Louisiana even penguins have
been spotted jaywalking in South Africa
the list of unusual wildlife sightings
goes on and on and on this cartoon
pretty much sums up the sentiment even
here on the campus of University of
Toronto Scarborough when I bike in I
routinely see deer now in campus the
major inhibitor of the movement of
animals across the city is traffic has
will be busy roads and now we've seen
major roads major arteries in the city
being almost devoid of cars this spring
traffic volumes in Toronto were cut in
half and those silent streets are also
providing a breath of fresh air
smoggy skylines from some of the world's
most polluted places are clearing the
contrast is even starker from space
revealing nitrogen dioxide emissions in
China and Italy before and after the
lockdown in India particle pollution
fell by nearly 60% we are seeing
improvements here in North America as
well during the pandemic speak Canada's
largest cities saw air pollution levels
highlighted here in blue drop by 15% I
would suspect that we could probably see
a 4050 percent reduction in the number
of smoggy days pollution kills seven
million people every year according to
the World Health Organization and some
experts expect that this cleaner air
might actually save more lives this year
than are lost to the virus and that
plummeting pollution is also sparking a
debate over whether the pandemic might
be flattening the climate curve 2020 is
witnessing a carbon crash co2 emissions
which fuel climate change are taking a
nosedive unlike anything we've seen
before
the reduction in in terms of tons of co2
which is what really matters for the
atmosphere we're definitely gonna have
by far the biggest reduction ever the
good news even as economies reopen
carbon emissions are expected to end the
year down around 8 percent the
equivalent of India's entire energy use
which brings us to the bad news even if
we get an 8% reduction this year that's
that's the sort of magnitude of
reduction we would need this year next
year the year after and every single
year in order to limit warming to 1.5
degrees to meet the Paris summit goal
and prevent the worst of climate change
global emissions need to fall by 7.6
percent every year for a decade even
this unprecedented lockdown amounts to
little more than a first step
basically we need this kind of reduction
every year and we don't want to have a
pandemic to do that we don't want to
have an economic recession to do that
and so we're gonna need to make
relatively large changes and some
believe this moment represents our best
chance for that chain
a golden opportunity to go green we all
get up every morning we get into our
cars we try we go to meetings all over
the world and everywhere all the time
and now we've learned hello I think we
can do this things a lot better Jatin
Nath Juana's office offers a glimpse
into a sustainable future a zero carbon
building one of Canada's first with a
solar paneled roof and geothermal
heating the University of Waterloo
professor believes this economic crisis
offers a chance to invest in these
technologies he points to the last time
carbon emissions dropped following the
global recession in 2009 governments
then responded by pumping billions into
stimulus projects construction designed
to boost the economy but that also saw a
sharp spike in emissions
there wasn't anything green about it
because there's typically not much green
about you know expanding a road or
building a bridge or putting a new roof
on the community ring but this time
round many countries are eyeing a
so-called green recovery the European
Union is making climate change the
centerpiece of its trillion dollar
investment a stimulus package steering
away from fossil fuels and towards
energy-efficient projects France is
offering financial aid to beleaguered
Airlines but only in exchange for
investments in lower emission aircraft
even China the world's largest emitter
has endorsed big spending on a slew of
low-carbon infrastructure albeit while
still building new coal plants I believe
that this is going to be different and
will be different partly because the
recognition the notion that we are
really facing a very severe climate
change question is no longer a matter of
debate the United States may prove the
exception as the white house steadily
slashes green protections but what about
Canada so far the federal government has
pledged 1.7 billion to clean up orphaned
and abandoned oil and gas wells in
Alberta Saskatchewan and BC salvaging
thousands of jobs if we can put some of
the people who were displaced out of the
oil patch
back to work into the cleanup process
then that actually is you know he's
helping in that labor market Canada's
oil sector was already reeling before
the pandemic pushed gas prices down
another twenty percent
analysts predict demand for oil may take
years to fully recover I think we're
seeing a transformation here that is
quite fundamental that decouples our
dependence on oil and fossil fuels he
argues this pandemic presents an
opportunity to fast track the transition
to renewable energy we should aim for an
orderly phase-out an orderly transition
to efficiency electric vehicles rather
than trying to prop up and maintain an
industry that has no long-term future
the government is being offered an
opportunity on a golden platter platter
but I'm not too confident that they will
take that opportunity political will to
push drastic change can be hard to come
by in normal times but this is anything
but the pandemic has seen millions heed
the advice of experts to protect against
an invisible threat the Canadian public
has listened we've stayed home we
physically distance we are listening to
medical experts and their advice to keep
us safe now we need to do the same thing
when it comes to climate change to
protect the future not only for
ourselves but also our furry friends
next on the new reality setting the
stage I'm not sure if this is the way of
the future it's kind of the way of the
present a new reality of concerts for
performers and fans there's so much
information surrounding coronavirus out
there now we know you have questions
email your questions at Global News Don
CA tune in to global national or go to
global MCA / coronavirus now to find the
answers
remember the good old days when you
could go to a concert and you could
thrive off all that energy in the crowd
well bands wanted back and they're
looking for ways to perform onstage in
front of a live audience
Canadian country music star Brett Kissel
seems to have cracked it he's come up
with a kind of throwback solution
drive-in concerts
kind of like drive-in theaters you pull
up stay in your vehicle and listen to
the band Brett Kissel talked to me from
the stage in Edmonton on Friday Brett so
good to talk to you I love the slogan on
your website tough times don't last
tough people do give us the basics of
how these drive-in concerts of yours are
gonna work I really appreciate that
tough times don't last stuff people do
as a model that I live by it's one of my
songs we actually just re-released it
for the weekend and I'm really excited
that we get to play that show for our
concerts our show here that we're doing
and all eight of them are very unique
because there's no speakers hung up on
the stage as you can see what it is is
that people are gonna hear our show
through the radio dials so we perform
into our sound board a sound board into
an FM transmitter transmitter into
everybody's car stereos we're just
asking that everybody honked their horns
when they like the song that they hear
oh nice so honking instead of clapping I
guess and I the idea is nobody gets out
of their vehicles right that's right I
mean safety is a huge concern for us we
have to make sure that everybody is
going to be safe but also have a great
time so we've got all of these rules on
our website drivin Brett Kissel calm
where we say some of these I guess scary
rules but we put a little country spin
on them so one of the big things was no
washrooms so please go before the show
and also no no tailgating we know
everybody wants to but stay in your
vehicle so we can entertain you through
the radio dial and what kind of response
have you've been getting how our ticket
sales it's been amazing for us to have
been able to sell out eight shows in
under an hour
when we put tickets on sale a couple of
weeks ago was something that really
shattered my expectations but one of the
really cool things is that both of the
shows that we are doing to you know
obviously to start our weekend has been
this it's for the
frontline workers first responders
health care heroes so those first two
shows have been free but the other ones
are obviously for the general public
what's really cool is that thanks to our
partnership with Safeway Canada 100% of
our proceeds go straight to the food
banks here in Alberta that way we can do
a lot of good and raise a lot of money
for a cause and an organization that
really needs it well for sure just give
us quickly Brett a sense of how your
community your province has been coping
with the pandemic what are some of the
stories you've heard from people well
Canadians in general are very tough here
in my province of Alberta we've
definitely been hit by tough times but I
know we're all trying to look for the
silver lining in this and that's why I
wanted to do this concert to raise
spirit for Albertans as well as do it as
we've now announced that we've got three
sold-out shows in Regina Saskatchewan
next weekend so maybe this thing might
snowball into a few more shows in a few
more places do you think this might be
the way of the future Bret that others
will start copying you you know what I'm
not sure if this is the way of the
future it's kind of the way of the
present right now this is the best that
we can do to bring people together and
bring live music back but as far as I'm
concerned I hope we get back to regular
scheduled programming and we get an
opportunity to play that the real shows
the real way that we want you know
hopefully very soon
we'll be right back on the new reality
[Music]
that's our program for this week
here are some of the stories we're
working on at the new reality how will
the pandemic change offices and how we
work many of us have been working from
home could that become permanent and if
we do go back to work how our shared
workspace is going to have to adapt to
be safe workplaces plus we've told you
about how pro sports are slowly
returning to action but what about our
younger athletes we look at the new
reality of organized sports and how our
kids can play safely in a distanced
world and a reminder you can find more
stories about the new reality on our
website Global News CA / the new reality
I'm Dona Friesen thanks for watching
[Music]